déterrez préoccupante dans plusieurs
régions françaises notamment l'île de
france où le directeur général de la
santé ne n'écarte pas l'idée d'un
reconfirmant pour soulager les hôpitaux
sous tension l'exécutif a annoncé le
lancement d' évacuation de grande
ampleur
elles ont commencé ce week-end et
s'accéléreront
dès demain
[Musique]
allik au vide en toile de fond des
élections législatives aux pays-bas
rassemblement à la et ce dimanche pour
protester contre les restrictions
sanitaires dans le collimateur des
protestataires l'actuel premier ministre
néerlandais mark rutte eux qui devaient
être reconduits pour un quatrième mandat
le scrutin s'ouvre demain il y aura
trois jours
[Musique]
la centrafrique vaut-elle aujourd'hui
pour lé second tour des législatives le
premier dans une majorité de bureau
puisque moins d'un électeur sur trois
avait eu accès aux urnes fin décembre le
temps avait été perturbée en pleine
offensive des rebelles sur la capitale
bangui aucun incident majeur signalé ce
dimanche même si l'année muscat sûr que
le vote a été empêché donc certaines
zones du thé
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france 1re confinement
de l'île de france n'est pas tabou
prévient jérôme un salomon le directeur
général de la santé a évoqué ce dimanche
la situation sanitaire jugée inquiétante
dans la région et si le nombre de
malades du coc u19 hospitalisés en
france s'est stabilisé autour de 25
mille le nombre de patients placés en
réanimation lui est en hausse
près de 4100 dont plus du quart en ile
de france face au risque de saturation
dans ses services francilien le
gouvernement a lancé ce week-end une
opération d'évacuation de malades vers
d'autres régions
elle s'accélère à partir de demain une
centaine d'évacuations sont prévues la
semaine prochaine
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel at elle qui a
assisté ce matin depuis l'aéroport
d'orly au transfert de deux malades vers
bordeaux
la situation est tendue préoccupante en
région ile de france
multipliant les évacuations sanitaires
parce que chaque ligue compte et nous
faisons tout pour ne pas avoir à prendre
des mesures plus difficile contraignante
pour les français les mesures qui sont
mises en place depuis plusieurs mois
elle pèse beaucoup je le sais sur le
quotidien des français et donc
évidemment nous avons à coeur à la fois
d'avoir les mesures qui sont les plus
efficaces en termes sanitaires et qui en
même temps son
le moins contraignante possible pour le
quotidien des français c'est toujours
cet équilibre que nous cherchons à
maintenir mais évidemment dès lors que
ce serait nécessaire nous prendrions
toutes les mesures appropriées
la nouvelle aquitaine où la pression
spital hier est plus faible se prépare
donc à l'arrivée de malades en
provenance d'île de france
écoutez ce médecin nous sommes préparés
à accueillir ses patientes donc hier dès
qu'on a appris ces mouvements de
patients on à libérer des lits qui a pas
de perte de chance dans la mesure où nos
collègues nous envoie des patients qui
sont relatifs relativement stable mais
qui ont besoin et bien d'un temps
d'hospitalisation arh animations
relativement long parce que c'est la
pathologie qui veut ça et donc les
patients qui sont transférées sont
transférés dans des conditions de grande
sécurité pour eux il n'y a pas du tout
de perte de chance est au contraire ils
vont se retrouver dans une ambiance où
la pression coville est moins importante
est où là
le niveau de soins on pourra être
amélioré pour ces patients pas de
confinement pour les départements d'île
de france quand les alpes maritimes
notamment sont-elles confiné pour le
troisième week-end consécutif une
injustice pour le président de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur
il dénonce traitement différent a
situation sanitaire pourtant comparable
entre nos gènes le torchon brûle entre
l'ile-de-france et les alpes-maritimes
en cause la stratégie vaccinale et les
mesures sanitaires prises par le
gouvernement au cas par cas avec un taux
d'incidence supérieur à celui de la
ville de nice
la seine saint denis devrait selon le
président ait l'air de la région paca
renaud muselier elle aussi être confiné
le week-end il y à une décision de
confinement en alpes-maritimes qui ne
correspond pas à des critères stable
équitable et compréhensible par la
population
et quand il ya une différence de
critères il ya forcément une différence
de traitement et donc il ya une
injustice quand les critères sont les
mêmes partout il doit y avoir le même
traitement par tous mais depuis le
départ c'est le bazar des critères le
taux d'incidence par département a été
défini en début d'année comme critère
déterminant pour savoir si les mesures
anti qu'ovide doivent être durcis ou
allégées et si pour le moment le taux
d'incidence globale en france est bien
au dessus du seuil d'alerté
seul le pas de calais la ville de
dunkerque nice et son littoral subissent
un confinement le week end
un problème qui pour le maire de nice
christian estrosi pourrait être résolu
grâce à la vaccination
je suis en mesure de disposer rapidement
pour la métropole de nice de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de doses de
spoutnik v le vaccin russe utilisé dans
plus de 40 pays du monde
je demande aux autorités de santé
demande donné l'autorisation
si la polémique autour d'astrazeneca et
son efficacité remise en question a
dissuadé une partie des français de
vouloir être vaccinés le gouvernement de
l'ap à retirer du marché et le laisse
parmi les vaccins autorisés en france
aux côtés de ceux produits par moderna
et faïza audio high tech
actuellement le plus couramment utilisé
avec plus de 5 millions de doses
injectées pourtant l'utilisation du
vaccin russe spoutnik v dont
l'efficacité est annoncée à 90% n'est
toujours pas à l'ordre du jour puisque
aucune pré commande n'a été fait depuis
le lancement de la campagne de
vaccination le 27 décembre dernier
environ 7% des français ont reçu au
moins une dose de vaccin tandis qu'à
peine plus de 3 % ont reçu les deux
doses
à ce rythme l'objectif fixé par le
gouvernement de vacciner l'ensemble de
la population adulte ne serait pas
atteint avant le 4 juillet 2022
le gouvernement s'est fixé l'objectif de
10 millions de personnes vaccinées
chenilles avril priorité est donnée aux
critères de santé plutôt qu'aux critères
professionnels à les enseignants devront
donc encore patienter au qui s'estime
pourtant en première ligne elle c'est le
choix de la france quand ailleurs dans
le monde à l'italie le portugal où les
états unis seront te donner leur feu
vert à la vaccination pour le personnel
enseignant
tour d'horizon avec maxime amer
la france compte 900 mille enseignants
pourtant paris a choisi de ne pas leur
donner deux priorités pour la
vaccination contre le coc vide
seuls les plus de 75 ans et les
professionnels de santé ont le droit
pour l'instant de recevoir les deux
doses nécessaires
il faut également y ajouter les quelques
millions de personnes atteintes de
comorbidité et présentant des
pathologies comme le diabète
l'hypertension ou des antécédents de
cancer
cette stratégie est bien différente chez
certains de nos voisins européens en
allemagne l'enseignement tient du
ressort des états régionaux mais le
ministre de la santé s'est mis d'accord
avec les länder
les enseignants des écoles primaires
sont désormais prioritaires dans
certaines régions la vaccination des
enseignants a même démarré en basse-saxe
feu vert a été donné pour la vaccination
des enseignants du premier degré en
espagne les enseignants du premier et du
second
° ont commencé à se faire vacciner fin
février ils font partie de la deuxième
vague de vaccination du pays puisque
madrid avait donné la priorité aux
soignants depuis septembre l'espagne n'a
pas refermé ses écoles chez ses voisins
portugais la phase de vaccination des
enseignants comment sera la fin du mois
en italie les personnes enseignante font
partie des catégories prioritaires sur
les 6 millions de doses administrées
plus de 500 mille professeurs et
personnels scolaires en ont reçu au
moins une direction maintenant le
continent américain aux etats-unis comme
en allemagne ce sont les états fédéraux
qui gère les campagnes de vaccination
comme le personnel soignant ou les
maisons de retraite les enseignants y
sont prioritaires 30 états américains
sur 50 ont déjà lancé leurs plans de
vaccination des enseignants joe biden
espère que tous les professeurs
recevront au moins une dose d'ici fin
mars
le pérou lui fait face à une pénurie de
vaccins les injections n'ont commencé
que le 9 février dernier et était
d'abord destiné aux agents de santé aux
personnels militaires et policiers
depuis le 4 mars sont les plus de 80 ans
qui peuvent recevoir la piqûre lima ne
prévoit pas d'inclure ces enseignants
dans la campagne de vaccination puisque
les cours ne se font toujours pas en
présentiel
politique inverse oshii mi février les
enseignants ont commencé à se faire
vacciner
le but rouvrir les écoles au 1er mars
513 1621 professeur assistant directeur
d'établissement ou employés de cantine
doivent recevoir le vaccin
les écoles chilienne étaient restés
fermés une bonne partie de l'année
scolaire précédente et ce soir le
premier ministre était l'invité du
journaliste samuel etienne assure tweet
jean castex appel à avoir confiance en
masse tracé n'est qu'à et à se faire
vacciner
il a été interrogé également sur la
possibilité d'une vaccination
obligatoire pour les personnels
soignants
écoutez sa position les soignants sont
les soldats de la première ligne
il faut que nous les convaincre qu'ils
ont de se faire vacciner c'est un
impératif national
apparemment le gouvernement est entendue
puisque l'auto de vaccination progresse
il est de l'ordre de 40% il y a encore
des réticences mais le mouvement est
bien engagée ce n'est que si nous ne
parvenions pas à vacciner tout le monde
que nous pourrions prendre des mesures
supplémentaires et les cinémas font à
leur tour de la résistance des
projections de films et est organisée ce
week-end dans une vingtaine de salles un
peu partout en france et dans des
conditions sanitaires très strictes
un premier test non officiel pour
encourager à la réouverture des stalles
une opération dans la foulée du
mouvement d'occupation des théâtres
toujours le même mot d'ordre donc il
faut rouvrir les lieux culturels
notre reporter n'avait jamais razak
était devant le cinéma le trianon à
romainville seine saint denis
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont
participé à ce rassemblement aujourd'hui
devant le cinéma le trianon à
romainville en seine-saint-denis cinéma
est classé monument historique 1 par le
ministère de la culture alors ce
dimanche 14 mars on célèbre un triste
anniversaire puisque cela fait
maintenant un an que la première
fermeture des salles obscures a été acté
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire
alors sur cette dernière année on
déplore deux cent quarante quatre jours
deux fermetures pour les salles de
cinéma jamais au cours de l'histoire les
cinémas n'avait été fermée aussi
longtemps même pas en période de guerre
mondiale alors ce que demandent ces
manifestants et bien c est la
réouverture immédiate des salles
obscures le directeur de ce cinéma ici
se dit même prêt à mettre en place un
protocole sanitaire stricte je vous
propose de l'écouter
les études partout dans le monde ont
démontré qu'il n'y a eu aucun cas de
contamination par la copie de 19 qui a
été déclaré dans un cinéma on a comme
sanitaire qui aurait connu comme étant
un des plus strictes et un des plus
compatibles le dire avec le la
propagation de l'épidémie
donc ici la salle fait 420 places on a
moyen même en réduisant encore les
jauges d'accueillir le public dans
d'excellentes conditions sanitaires
cette fermeture des salles obscures et
qualifié d' in logique et d'
incompréhensible par de nombreux
manifestants et coûté c'est quand même
pas normal je dire que ce serait pas
ouvert alors que bon les commerces ont
rouvert même si leurs vieux là un petit
peu différemment mais voilà ça serait
bien qu'ils rouvrent d'autant plus que
bon faut pas responsable par rapport à
la situation si quelqu'un est
responsable bas on pense comme moi je
pense que c'est le gouvernement anc a
manqué que j'aille par rapport aux
masques par rapport aux gets par rapport
à la vaccination
on arrivera à sion avec siné est bon ce
qui paye
je suis allé au cinéma cet été il y
avait des normes de sécurité qui était
tout à fait respecté avec le masque avec
l'espacement dans les dents les sièges
donc je vois pas pourquoi c'est pas
réouvert moi personnellement je suis
enseignant je fais court tous les jours
a entre 25 et 75 enfants qui portent le
masque et ça en droit de le faire tel
cinéma me manque énormément comme et à
aucune activité plus rien
donc et puis pour se tenir aussi les
intermittents du spectacle tous le monde
de la culture
c'est vrai tout est fermé ça nous manque
énormément
l'appel à la réouverture des salles de
cinéma et des lieux de culture plus
généralement sera-t-il entendu par le
gouvernement
rien n'est moins sûr pourquoi et bien
parce que la situation sanitaire se
dégrade de jour en jour que le nombre de
contaminations explose et que
l'hypothèse d'un troisième confinement
du révoquer un temps au mois de janvier
est rejetée eh bien on se fait
aujourd'hui de plus en plus insistantes
et réactions à présent de laurent
benoist délégué général du syndicat des
professionnels de l'industrie de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma
il ya très peu de contamination sur les
lieux de travail et notamment sur les
lieux de tournage
nous pensons qu'il y a moyen
effectivement de trouver et de mettre en
place un dispositif qui permettrait de
réouvrir un certain nombre de lieux
consacrés au spectacle l'essentiel des
camarades chez nous qui travaillent pour
les pour les plateformes en eau
beaucoup de travail donc on va pas on va
pas s'en plaindre mais on craint
effectivement à l'horizon deux des 12 18
mois dix-huit mois prochain que est la
mise en production de films et déjà on
observe auprès du centre national de la
cinématographie que la mise en
production des films à venir se
ralentisse toujours en france
rassemblement à paris contre la loi
séparatisme à l'appel de plusieurs
associations et à la veille de la
journée mondiale contre l'islamophobie
le texte qui vise à conforter le respect
des principes de la république a été
adopté par les députés
il est examiné par la commission des
lois du sénat depuis le 1er mars avant
sa discussion en séance plénière à
partir du 30 mars
plusieurs dispositifs de la loi pose
problème aux organisateurs de cette
mobilisation ils dénoncent entre autres
un ciblage des musulmans notre reporter
lucas dg a suivi le rassemblement
parisien
ces manifestants étaient rassemblés ici
sur la place de la république pour
lutter contre l'islamophobie et contre
les lois qui est juge aux islamophobes
en premier lieu desquels la loi sur les
séparatismes ils craignent avec cette
loi de se retrouver stigmatisés en tant
que musulman ce qui selon eux est une
véritable entorse à la liberté
religieuse notre liberté selon eux qui
est bafouée par cette loi la liberté
d'association
ils craignent des dissolutions massive
d'organisation mais je vous propose
d'écouter plusieurs manifestants que
j'ai pu interviewer au début de cette
manifestation il y à une loi qui est
débattu maintenant au sénat
ce qu'il soit raciste qui loi
islamophobe qui est une déclaration de
guerre contre la communauté musulmane et
contre les musulmans en france avec la
volonté de vouloir les rabaisser les
déshumaniser et les chasser de las de la
vie sociale et politique publique
c'est-à-dire y ait une volonté de
cantonner les musulmans et l'islam à la
secteur privé et que toutes expressions
publiques sociales culturelles
cultuelles et politique de l'islam est
une volonté de la condamnée et de la
chasse et de l'espacement la cette loi
c'est une loi c'est tout qui veulent
faire une loi séparatiste a comme ça
c'est très mauvais pour la france et
c'est très mauvais pour le peuple
et parce que petit à petit je pense je
pense qu'il ya aussi les syndicalistes
et après tout associations quelles
qu'elles soient a sera réprimée de la
même manière que les gens vous tous qui
se mettent donc d'être bien dans la tête
que c'est l'appareil
cet appel à manifester il intervient à
la veille d'une journée internationale
contre l'homophobie
il ya la veille d'une commémoration
celle de l'attentât de christchurch en
nouvelle zélande à 12,51 musulmans
avaient été assassinés par le visionnage
comme martin taraabt c'était le 15 mars
2010 9 octobre c'est aussi l'occasion
pour eux de réclamer le retrait d'une
loi une loi votée en 2004 sur
l'interdiction du hidjab du voile à
l'école et dans les établissements
scolaires plus tout le monde
nouvelle déconvenue pour le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
après le danemark la norvège l'islande
et la bulgarie l'irlande est devenu ce
dimanche le 5e pays en europe à
suspendre l'utilisation du sérum du
laboratoire à studio britannique la
région italienne du piémont elle a
décidé la suspension dans l'eau après la
mort d'un enseignant vacciner des
mesures de précaution francs raison de
craintes liées à la formation de
caillots sanguins aucun lien de cause à
effet et n'est pour l'heure clairement
établie à mai la liste des effets
secondaires liés au vaccin d'astrazeneca
ne cesse de s'allonger
après le risque d'allergies sévères on
évoque désormais des hémorragies cutanée
chez des jeunes vacciner un nouveau coup
dur pour astrazeneca est déjà incapable
de livrer les quantités de doses
promises dans lieu aujourd'hui nous
avons reçu trois rapports
supplémentaires concernant des caillots
sanguins graves ou des hémorragies
cérébrales chez des personnes plus
jeunes ayant reçu le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
ces personnes sont traitées à l'hôpital
jusqu'à présent nous ne pouvons pas dire
si ces cas sont liés au vaccin mais en
raison de la gravité de ces cas nous
menons une enquête approfondie
les examens médicaux sont effectués en
coopération avec l'hôpital universitaire
d'oslo
par conséquent nous demandons à toutes
les personnes de moins de 50 ans qui ont
reçu le vaccin astrazeneca au cours des
14 derniers jours de consulter leur
médecin ou de se rendre aux urgences si
elles sont malades après plusieurs jours
ou si elles présentent des taches bleues
plus ou moins grande ou des saignements
de la peau en italie se prépare au
confinement la vie avait repris son
cours ces derniers mois avec la
réouverture dans certaines villes des
cafés des restaurants
mais depuis quelques semaines le pays
fait face à une troisième vague de
contamination dès demain près de 40
millions d'italiens vont donc à passer
en zone rouge
à part quelques régions comme la
sardaigne c'est presque l'intégralité de
l'italie qui est concerné par ces
nouvelles mesures et
semblable à celle appliquée lors du
premier confinement à savoir la
fermeture des écoles des bars des
restaurants et des commerces non
essentiels ce dimanche les italiens ont
donc profité comme ils ont pu de leurs
derniers moments de liberté
nous sommes obligés de limiter notre
liberté
je pense que c'est nécessaire pour le
moment et bien sûr nous continuerons sur
cette voie tant que ce sera nécessaire
jusqu'à ce que nous soyons au moins tous
vaccinés
bien sûr c'est très difficile surtout
pour ceux qui n'ont pas de travail je
vis ce jour vous savez comme un dernier
jour de confort et peut-être un moment
d'espoir pour des temps meilleurs
malheureusement ces situations changent
souvent on sait on ne sait pas donc je
souhaite le meilleur à tout le monde
j'espère que les choses vont s'améliorer
et non pas empirer l'espoir et des
seules choses
elles sont considérées comme le premier
test politique majeur d'un gouvernement
européen depuis le début de la pandémie
les élections législatives aux pays-bas
le scrutin s'ouvre demain il durera
trois jours un scrutin sur fond de
contestations des restrictions
sanitaires
de nouvelles manifestations
antigouvernementales se sont déroulés à
dans la journée à la haye des centaines
de protestataires se sont rassemblés
pour dénoncer entre autres le couvre feu
instauré par le premier ministre libéral
mark rutte eux qui devraient être
reconduits pour un quatrième mandat
disons qu'il est au pouvoir mais cette
fois ci en seul sujet de préoccupation
la pandémie et ses conséquences
économiques
walid de l'année
impossible de passer à côté panneau
publicitaire affiche de campagne
les élections législatives enjeux
majeurs du futur printemps néerlandais
une nouvelle saison marquée par
l'empreinte du coc vide 19 sujet dans
toutes les têtes des politiques et des
votants je pense qu'il ya des
discussions sur d'autres sujets mais
bien sûr principalement sur le
coronavirus l'impact des mesures et les
décisions sur la crise du coc vides font
bien évidemment partie du débat pour
cela laisse moins de place à d'autres
sujets le parti libéral vvd est au
gouvernement depuis un certain temps et
je pense qu'il a eu beaucoup de
scandales auxquels ils n'auraient
peut-être pas survécu si le coronavirus
n'était pas là par exemple celui autour
des allocations familiales c'est très
important et je ne pense pas qu'ils
auraient pu avoir autant de sièges
si le coronavirus n'était pas là
le parti populaire pour la liberté la
démocratie de marque route eu en tête
des sondages dirige une coalition de
quatre partis celui de l'appel chrétien
démocrate celui de l'union chrétienne ou
encore le d66 de centre gauche un
gouvernement pourtant démissionnaire
début janvier une vingtaine de milliers
de famille accusée à tort de fraude aux
allocations familiales
toujours au pouvoir et en charge des
affaires courantes jusqu'à la tenue des
élections le premier ministre marcourt
ou te joue la carte de la prudence et de
l'espoir face au co vite sceptiques
depuis le 1er mars les salons de
coiffure et de massage en rouvert tout
comme partiellement les lycées et
collèges
malgré un couvre-feu de 21h à 4h30 du
matin prolongé jusqu'au 31 mars locaux
vides 19 qui tend à éclipser d'autres
problématiques
selon le chef de la seconde formation
politique du pays
d'autres questions comme l'immigration
sont aussi importantes pour mes
électeurs c'est toujours la question
numéro 1 mais pour le néerlandais moyens
le coc vider sa principale préoccupation
le premier ministre a exclu d'inclure
dans son gouvernement le parti de geert
wilders
très actif sur les réseaux sociaux
pandémie oblige le parti de la gauche
verte groenlinks espère lui pouvoir
rejoindre la future coalition au pouvoir
marc route eux 54 ans est l'un des
dirigeants européens ayant la plus
grande longévité à ce poste
l'homme a entamé sa onzième année à la
tête des pays bas les sondages de sortie
des urnes annonce une lourde défaite des
conservateurs d'angela merkel deux
länder de l'ouest de l'allemagne a voté
ce dimanche pour renouveler leur
parlement régional le baden wurttemberg
et la rhénanie-palatinat la cd ou de la
chancelière allemande y seraient très
largement devancé elle devrait même
obtenir le pire score de son histoire
dans ce scrutin jugé décisif pour le
parti ya six mois des législatives en
vote sanction pour le camp merkel
fragilisée par les rats tech dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire est englué
dans un scandale financier autour de
contrats d'achat de masse quantico vide
les conservateurs promettent ce soir là
tolérance zéro face aux malversations
élections législatives en centrafrique
second tour mais aussi premier dont de
nombreux bureaux là où l'accès aux urnes
n'avaient pas été assurées fin décembre
en pleine offensive des rebelles sur la
capitale bangui aujourd'hui le contexte
sécuritaire et plus apaisé mais reste
fragile surtout dans les campagnes là où
les groupes armés replier menace
toujours selon la minus cannes vote
aujourd'hui a été empêchée dans
certaines zones du pays
aucun incident majeur n'a toutefois été
signalé pour ces électeurs se déplacer
aux urnes était une nécessité
je constate malheureusement que
contrairement au 25 décembre il n'y a
pas un véritable engouement
mais si vous voulez d'une manière
générale c'est ce qui se passe parce que
et à la culture électorale que les gens
n'ont pas nécessairement ailleurs jugé
que l'injure étions un peu partout en
afrique
quand les gens votent une première fois
il ne voit plus l'utilité de voter une
seconde fois parce que qu'ils se disent
on a comptabilisé le roi comme les
textes sont là les textes disque dont un
bon citoyen c'est celui qui doivent
voter mais c'est simple mais bien que al
et sécurité dans le pays
oui d'accord mais j'irai voter et ça
c'est ça c'est primordial
mon travail est la junte birmane déclare
la loi martiale dans deux communes de
rangoon nouvel épisode de la répression
menée par l'armée chez à l'égard des
protestataires
ils manifestent presque sont relâche le
fit le coup d'état militaire qui a
renversé l'ex dirigeante aung san suu
kyi 18 personnes ont à nouveau été tuées
ce dimanche lors de nouvelles
manifestations
environ 70 personnes au total auraient
trouvé la mort en près d'un mois et demi
selon l'onu plusieurs députés se sont
regroupés en un parlement fantôme
constitué par d'ex élus passé à la
clandestinité pour la plupart l'agente a
prévenu que cette formation s'apparenter
à une haute trahison passible d'une
peine de 22 ans de prison dans une vidéo
publiée sur facebook un dirigeant de
l'opposition a lancé un appel à la
résistance contre cette dictature
injuste selon ses mots en l'écoutant
c'est la période la plus sombre de la
nation et le moment avant l'aube
alors à nous ce culte aurons notre futur
avec notre force unie sans céder à la
dictature injuste je voudrais conclure
que l'union démocratique fédérale que
nous espérons nous attendra dans un
avenir proche si nous avons sont unis et
avec invincibilité il faut que le
soulèvement l'emportent et c'est la fin
de cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
je vous retrouve dans une trentaine de
minutes pour un nouveau journal à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara occidental
la france comme l'europe a été absente
de l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume
humain des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifique
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]